اول شيء يعني خلينا نشوف الخطا الموجود
بعدين نشوف
النموذجيه يعني اذا الخطا مثلا مفهوم
الدراما الان هم فصلوا بشكل خاطئ الافلام
يسمونه افلام روائيه الافلام روائيه
الطويله او الفيلم القصير المسلسلات
يسمونه اعمال الدراميه
المسرح ضايع ما هذا مو موجود يعني كيف
يعني كيف وزعوا توزيعها هذه وكيف قسموها
انا ما ادري كيف العمل الدرامي واحد ممكن
يكون مسرح ممكن يكون فيلم ممكن يكون ممكن
يكون سينما ممكن يكون مسلسل العمل الدرامي
بتفاصيل واحد ممكن يكون هذه كلها قواعد
قوالب اي لكن تقول لا والله الفيلم وهو
عمل روائي
90% افلام هوليود
لما انت قلت بالضبط
يعني اعطيك اياها بالضبط طبعا في تجديد في
تغيير في اشياء بسيطه لكن
ليست نظريه
ماذا تنصح زملائك السعوديين في هذا
الصناعه التاهيل الاكاديمي مهم جدا لان
التحيه لاكاديمي بخلل الفكر الفكر خلينا
نقول علمي همم كل المصطلحات واضحه باينه
وكل يعني كل نظريه حتى كل المدارس تصير
وضعها في ذهنه اذا هو عمل شيء يعرف موقعه
يعرف انا
مهم جدا جدا